today we're making chocolate cake but
there's just one rule we can't produce
any waste and i'm terrified
i'm sarah and i run matchbox kitchen i
write about sustainability i've led a
zero waste lifestyle for about two and a
half years now and we're gonna see who
makes less waste food waste is not
necessarily a bad thing a lot of it can
be composted so not all waste is bad
waste but for the sake of this challenge
we're gonna try to have zero waste we
actually have another channel good full
that focuses on sustainability and
healthy recipes check it out
i don't really know what is in the bulk
aisle i've never shopped in the bulk
aisle so i'm hoping that the ingredients
that i need are there i don't see like
baking soda or any kind of leavener
maybe we can find a baking soda with
like the least amount of packaging so
i'm gonna grab this baking soda which
does come packaged but it is a
recyclable paper being zero waste
doesn't mean you make absolutely no
waste at all it's about being conscious
about the choices you make to reduce the
amount of trash you create hey sarah so
i actually am purchasing baking soda too
oh great but i feel like maybe we should
just split it yeah because obviously we
don't need this much perfect and then
cut down our waste honestly the hardest
part about this has been filling these
containers clean clean
cheese okay i need an apron this is
really exciting
[Music]
i'm thinking of making a vegan chocolate
cake the only thing i'm worried about is
they usually use oil and because i can't
buy that package free i don't know what
i'm going to do to replace it yet i know
obviously that eggs come in a carton so
i'm going to try to switch eggs out for
a flax egg and i know i'm going to be
eyeballing a lot of things in the bulk
aisle so might be kind of tricky this
will be fun though i hope we get a cake
at the end instead of using milk i'm
going to be making my own cashew milk
just by blending cashews and water
together i don't have a source of fat
for my cake so i'm going to have to
think of some sort of substitution for
butter or oil that all comes in
packaging we have mini chocolate peanut
butter cups
maybe i can melt those down and add it
to the cake this can be my source of
chocolate my source of sweetness and my
source of fat it actually might work to
make a really fudgy chocolate cake this
is all new territory for me i'm not sure
if this is gonna work i have seen some
recipes where people make a chocolate
avocado pudding and i think i might do
something like that to make a frosting
for the cake i am nervous about
some of the swaps that i'm making but
i'm excited to see how it turns out
i guess it's time to get baking i got
two jars of these mini peanut butter
cups and i'm just going to melt one down
because i want to save the other one for
maybe a frosting first i'm going to sift
all of the dry ingredients together i'm
also going to get my flax egg going this
is a really good substitution for vegans
but i'm using this in order to cut down
on waste it's like
slimy kind of like an egg consistency
would be i'm now going to mash up my
very ripe banana i'm going to make some
cashew milk and i just put some water
and cashews in here so i made the cashew
milk and then i added some coffee beans
to it she's getting really fancy with
this and i know i kind of played my cake
a little bit safer but i only have one
banana pail in my trash bin who's the
expert now
still her i'm not the expert so now i'm
gonna add my melted chocolate peanut
butter cups yum
i'm measuring out the avocado and now
i'm just gonna blend it all together so
it's smooth and there's no chunks of
avocado in it does the avocado taste
come through not really because
chocolate is such a strong flavor that
it pretty much masks most of the avocado
i didn't get anything to grease my pan
with
i mean it could use
parchment paper although that's trash
most parchment paper is compostable oh
although you should still be conscious
of using it mindfully well
guess i'm using parchment paper should i
do it again it's kind of a bummer
because i feel like i was doing so well
and now i'm like i don't know what to do
with all these scraps of parchment but
like i really need to line my cake tin
you're doing two small cakes i'm doing
one thing i'm doing a layered cake
i'm sure both cakes will come out
delicious
i have to say these look really good
yeah they look great too
i'm just nervous they're not going to
come out of the
tin
it works when the cakes came out of the
oven i was relieved that they rose but
they do seem a little dense so i'm a
little worried if they are hard inside
or not i still have a lot of chocolate
peanut butter cups left and i really
don't want to waste those so i'm
thinking i'm going gonna melt those down
and use it as a glaze for my cake
there's still a little bit of chunks
left but the residual heat will melt
those down to make the ganache frosting
first i made a chocolate ganache with
chocolate chips and cashew milk and then
i got the avocado and whipped that until
really smooth and fluffy once the
ganache is cool enough i'm going to mix
them together and then whip them even
more
you can't even taste the avocado i don't
know how much fat is in these peanut
butter cups so i'm hoping it works to
set like a ganache a nice chocolate
ganache you can't go wrong
what are you doing so i just cut off the
domes from my cakes to level them out a
bit and now i'm crumbling them up into
smaller pieces and i'm going to toast
them in the oven so it adds a nice
crunchy texture to the cake nice so
smart while we're waiting for those to
toast i'm going to brew a little bit of
coffee from the coffee beans that i
bought
so what is the coffee for i'm going to
just make a hot coffee to brush on top
of the cake layers to add some more
moisture and more flavor i'm going to
start putting my cake together instead
of using a disposable piping bag i like
to decorate my cakes with an offset
spatula you can still get a lot of
different designs and textures that way
for the second layer i like to put it
upside down that way that the flat side
is on top i'm going to keep it
relatively thinner on the sides just
because i don't want the frosting to be
overwhelming so my cake is set my
ganache kind of turned into a chocolate
shell but it's okay i don't really have
anything else to add on top oh i have
these things maybe i could do like a
little
oh
you know what this might actually be
pretty cool and i get a little abstract
design on there
it's like
stonehenge or something so now that my
crumbs are nice and toasty i'm going to
put them into the coffee grinder and
grind them into a powder that looks
really nice
thank you
did you
want to say anything about mine
i was really impressed by alex's efforts
because she didn't create any plastic
waste so far and the only things that
are in her trash bowl are all
compostable now i'm going to decorate
the top with my lemon that i used
earlier and just put a little lemon zest
that way it's not completely wasted
and that's it overall i'm pretty happy
with how the cake came out i really like
how it looks but again we haven't cut
into it so i don't know if it's going to
be dense or dry i'm actually really
pleased with this cake i'm excited to
try it i think it'll have a good amount
of chocolate flavor not the best
execution but points for creativity
aside from the parchment paper fiasco i
think i did a pretty good job of course
we can't let these cakes go to waste so
we're gonna have some people try them
out and see how they taste
wow beautiful when i was cutting out the
parchment i kind of messed up but i
figured we could use it as napkins
[Laughter]
oh yeah it's good it's moist it's very
moist it doesn't even need that much
chocolate on top i feel like the flavor
of the peanut butter goes a long way oh
wow layer wow okay
i like it's not too sweet i do feel
accomplished i mean you didn't even
create one piece of plastic waste which
is amazing
there's nothing like the taste of no
waste save the turtles
[Music]
[Applause]
you